Prof: Today I want to
talk about Stalinism,
and,
in doing so--fifteen years ago,
lots of what we now know about
the Soviet Union through its
entire history we didn't know,
because the archives weren't
open.
When the Soviet Union
collapsed, fell apart,
disintegrated in the early
1990s, gradually lots of the
archives were opened.
What I have to say today--I
don't work in the Soviet
Union--draws upon the work of
Peter Holquist.
He used to teach at Cornell and
now teaches at Princeton,
and more recent work on
Stalinism by Sheila Fitzpatrick.
Let me just lay out the
overview at the beginning.
I sent around this morning--I
didn't get home until real late
last night,
so I sent along at about 12:30
in the morning various terms,
but I forgot a
couple--democratic centralism,
right opposition,
and Bukharin--but this stuff is
all in the book.
I hope you're able to get that.
I'll do the same for next time.
The question remains:
did Lenin inevitably lead to
Stalin?
That's a hard one.
I guess basically the structure
of what morphed into the Soviet
regime was set,
the way that the Bolshevik
party operated,
even before taking power.
The fundamental concept was
democratic centralism.
That is the way that the Soviet
state became organized as a
top-down way of making decisions
and sending out relevant
communication.
In principle,
it was supposed to involve
debate at the highest levels.
Then, once decisions were
taken, then they were
communicated through the
Communist Party.
But, of course,
the sheer paranoia of
Stalin--he was,
as you know,
a clinical paranoid.
His paranoia led to the deaths
of millions of people.
Debate itself became,
as a concept under Stalinism,
identified with anti-Soviet
behavior.
Essentially,
what had begun as a popular
revolution on behalf of working
people--also,
to an extent,
on behalf of
nationalities--became the
dictatorship not of the
proletariat,
not of the proletariat but of
the Communist Party,
of the Bolshevik Party
transformed into the Communist
Party and the dictatorship of
Stalin.
Of course, as his paranoia
increased the purges followed.
The big show trials,
some of which where people,
Western communists went in,
and sat and listened to hear
people confess to having been in
cahoots with Nazis,
or with English royalists,
or whomever,
and confess to things that they
certainly had never done not
long before their execution.
One of the points to be made
today is,
following Peter Holquist,
that the structure of the
Stalinist terror--there were
antecedents that one could see
in the civil war,
and in the period of Lenin's
domination in the early years of
the Soviet Union.
But very early on,
the people who imagined that
nationalities would have
autonomy, those hopes were
destroyed quite quickly.
Stalin, he had been minister,
or whatever they called the
Commissar of Nationalities.
The idea that workers'
self-management,
self-control,
control of the means of
production,
would be implemented in this
new brave world was shattered
rather quickly with strikes and
protests by workers,
smashed by the police,
by the Soviet state.
The illusion would be
perpetuated in the 1920s,
and even in the 1930s,
that this was a true workers'
paradise, and that everything
was groovy.
But the talk was always about
the "radiant future."
Radiant was a word that they
used a lot.
I'll talk more about this in a
while.
The future would be radiant.
It would be glorious.
But the sacrifices had to be
made now,
and they had to be made now to
protect the revolution against
the Americans,
against the French,
and against the British,
and the powers of capitalism,
etc., etc.
Of course, as you all know,
it never came to be.
That's the tragedy of the
Russian Revolution.
Well, more about this in a
while.
First of all,
as backdrop to all of this,
because of the civil war,
and because of famine
conditions,
and because of just enormous
economic hardship,
trying to have a state--;it was
not clear how this could
possibly be done.
You've got a country with all
these nationalities,
which is basically still
essentially a country of
peasants,
despite the industrial work in
the Ural mountains,
and in the mines,
and in the town of Petrograd
that became Leningrad,
obviously, later.
You're going to know how to do
this.
The war itself,
as in all of the countries that
participated in World War I,
had done enormous ravages.
The Germans are fighting inside
Russia,
and the subsequent civil war
that decimated large parts of
the countryside left the country
barely able to function.
In 1921 and 1922,
this is in what you're reading,
more than seven million people
died of starvation and sickness
during that period.
Remember, the wars go on.
The war against Poland goes on
until finally the situation is
resolved with the Treaty of Riga
in 1921, which I don't think is
in your book.
Lenin implemented the New
Economic Policy.
As he and the other Soviet
leaders grappled with a country
in virtual collapse,
he recognized that the ideology
of communism,
which called for the abolition
of private property,
private ownership,
and the destruction of the free
market,
would have to be sacrificed for
the future.
You simply had to be able to
feed people.
You had to have peasants not
hoarding what they produced,
or waiting for higher prices.
You needed to have a free
market system,
at least for a while,
because of the fact that people
resisted,
which was what was called war
communism,
which was sort of a shock
communist therapy that had
proved not to really work at
all.
So, the New Economic Policy is
promulgated in March of 1921,
and the features of it you can
read about.
Basically, the state maintains
its centralized control over the
economy,
and there's still centralized
planning,
but the NEP allowed peasants to
use their land as if it was
their own, and largely,
in most cases it still was,
and allowed them to market
their products,
and sell them at market prices
in order to get food to people
who needed it.
Otherwise, they too would have
died.
The state maintained its
control over heavy industry.
But this is all going to be
just a small retreat along the
road to socialism.
It succeeded.
It works.
Gradually the production of
food reached prewar levels,
and small-scale industrial
production revives.
Another name I should have
written on the board--I was so
tired when I did all this last
night--is Kulaks.
Two groups of people who
profited during this period,
these two groups of people
would,
in the long memory of the
communist leadership,
get theirs during the Five Year
Plan.
The first are those people who,
for example,
were small merchants--not in
size,
but they sold products on the
free market and did very,
very well during this period of
the New Economic Policy.
They became known as NEP men.
NEP is the New Economic Policy,
and the NEP men were people who
did well during this period.
The other, and it's a term,
as we'll see in a while,
that became a term of
denigration,
and indeed could lead you
straight to the gulag if you
were lucky and weren't executed
before that, were Kulaks.
Kulaks basically were
prosperous peasants.
They were well-off peasants.
During the period of the New
Economic Policy the Kulaks,
the people with land who had
something to sell,
did well indeed,
because their goods fetched
good prices and they did very
well.
With the gradual ending of the
New Economic Policy,
which sort of trickles to an
end after Lenin,
they would become targets in
the mass collectivization
campaign that accompanied the
Five Year Plan,
that is 1928 to 1933,
and would be themselves victims
of the purges as we'll see.
The tragedy of the Russian
Revolution.
There's a quote in there
from--I guess it was somebody in
the Red Army who said,
"Did we do all this?
Did we fight in the civil war?
Did we try to save the
revolution against some really
basically horrible legions and
the white armies during the
civil war?
Did we save the revolution in
order to round up Kulaks,
and put them in the middle of a
field,
and line them up in the middle
of a field,
and gun them down with machine
guns to kill them?
Did we do all of this to
eliminate from the face of the
earth these people who had,
despite being relatively
privileged,
had struggled,
and had managed to survive the
whole thing?"
Sadly, the answer is yes.
It came to that.
The question is:
To what extent was this
automatically--was this part of
the system from the beginning?
I'll give you some examples
that Holquist cites in a minute.
He says you can see this coming
if you look at the first years
of the Soviet people.
Let me give you some examples
of this.
This is before the period where
Stalin becomes a success.
Stalin worked very hard to make
it seem--as Lenin had one stroke
and then another--Stalin tried
to keep access closed to other
people.
He worked feverishly to make it
seem that Stalin was the chosen
successor of Lenin.
There are some famous doctored
photographs where Stalin has had
himself inserted next to Lenin,
in famous poses of Lenin,
who was a pretty good speaker,
but nothing like Trotsky.
Trotsky, with Jean
Jaurès,
was the greatest orator of the
entire period.
But Lenin wasn't too bad.
Stalin literally had himself
stuck into pictures where he
would be there.
He also took some of Lenin's
writings and sort of
"updated"
them to make it seem like the
mantle was there.
As everybody knows who follows
this stuff at all,
Lenin was, in his final days,
most concerned that comrade
Stalin's leadership was
potentially very dangerous.
He expressed those fears in the
letter,
if I remember correctly,
written with a very shaky hand
of a man who had a stroke,
a very serious stroke,
and who was close to death.
He had his doubts about comrade
Stalin, not exactly from the
beginning.
Also, it's important to note
that Trotsky--whom as I said the
other day would finally be
tracked down and assassinated in
a garden in Mexico City--the
differences between Trotsky and
Stalin went beyond ideology.
Trotsky, in what became known
as the "left
opposition,"
that was pushing for more
active instigation of
revolutions in other places,
and, ironically,
was pushing even more for
collectivization even early on.
But it went more than that.
There was a rivalry between two
men who both were
extraordinarily sure of
themselves,
and who thought that they were
the person who should first
save,
and then lead,
the Soviet Union.
Trotsky's role in the Red Army
as a strategist was extremely
important.
But there was more than that
also.
There was more than a small
trace of anti-Semitism in
Stalin.
When he would refer to
"cosmopolitan
enemies,"
and things like that.
Cosmopolitanism was sort of a
code word for Jews,
for Jewish people within the
party.
There was more than that to
that.
Trotsky is expelled from the
party, and then finally is
tracked down and killed.
Some of these that you know
from reading Orwell,
some of these factions and
these differences play
themselves out in this
anticipation of World War II
that was the Spanish Civil War.
The followers of Trotsky are a
very important faction in the
Spanish Civil War.
You know from reading Orwell
the role of the Stalinists in
all of this.
Just a few things before I turn
to Holquist's argument about how
you can see some of the horrors
coming early on.
Let me just define Stalinism as
a term.
It's a set of tenets,
policies, and practices that
characterize the Soviet
government during the period
when Stalin is in power.
Stalinism lasts until Stalin
finally dies--when is it?
1953.
That is when Stalin dies.
The beginning of the Five Year
Plan, that is 1928 to 1933,
is really the real beginning of
Stalinism.
You can anticipate some of
this, as we'll see in a minute.
Stalinism not only takes a sort
of democratic centralism of
decision making,
but what it does is it employs
state coercion,
and more than this,
state terror,
with the goal of transforming
this still relatively backward
society into a Soviet state that
could sustain itself,
that could build heavy
industries.
This was the obsession of
Stalin and Stalinism,
that heavy industries would
have to be built,
and that they would be built on
the backs of the peasantry,
who would lose their land and
become industrial workers.
There's a massive urbanization,
as we'll see,
in the Soviet Union during this
period.
The obvious central
characteristics of Stalinism,
as you've already seen,
are the abolition of private
property, first of all,
and the end of free trade,
the end of the market.
The market is to disappear.
If you're abolishing private
property in a vast,
vast state,
in which two generations before
you still had serfs,
what you want to do from their
point of view is collectivize
agriculture.
The massive collectivization of
This would, as you know,
become a characteristic of the
satellite states in Eastern
Europe and Eastern Central
Europe with varying degrees,
varying degrees in those states.
The economy is planned.
It's run in a centralized
fashion and predicated upon mass
industries, rapid
industrialization.
Part of this was the
liquidation--not a nice word--of
those "exploiting
classes,"
that is the bourgeois,
the NEPmen, the Kulaks,
the aristocrats,
and the clergy.
This involves deporting people
to the gulags,
or incarcerating them wherever
they were, or incarcerating them
in the gulags.
The purge, the terror,
the political terror against
alleged enemies,
including those who disagreed
with Stalin within the
leadership of the Soviet Union.
Thus, the purges that you can
read about of the left
opposition of Zinoviev and
Trotsky, and Bukharin's right
opposition.
With this comes the cult of
personality.
Stalin himself becomes,
and I say this in quotes,
"a czar-like figure."
There are still truck drivers
in Russia who have pictures of
Stalin in their trucks,
and other people as well.
This leads, obviously,
to kind of half-baked political
scientists' interpretations,
"Well, you have a czarist
state.
You have an autocracy.
Inevitably it becomes another
autocracy with a czar-like
figure, the cult of personality
of Stalin."
When you think of Mao's China,
and there the cult of
personality, if anything,
was even more than that with
the Little Red Book and
all of this business.
To repeat the obvious,
the Soviet Union was the
dictatorship of the Communist
Party,
and the dictatorship of the
Communist Party was the
dictatorship of Joseph Stalin,
and the paranoia of Joseph
Stalin.
Now, ironically,
Stalin, as I'm sure you know,
was not Russian,
even though the Soviet Empire,
and it was that,
was largely run in the interest
of Russia and Russians.
Stalin was a Georgian.
He was from the country in
which all these things have
happened in just the last five
or six months.
He started out as a seminary
student.
He was expelled for reading
Marxist tracts.
Like a lot of these people,
he took aliases,
because he robbed banks to get
money for the Bolshevik party.
Stalin means in Russian
"man of steel."
That was his alias.
That wasn't his original name.
Remember, he's a Georgian.
As I just said,
he becomes the administrator,
the Commissar of Nationalities,
but determined to snap the head
off of the "hydra,"
of the danger of nationalist
revival in these states.
Communism, in theory,
was antithetical to
nationalism;
although, ironically,
as you all know,
it doesn't really work that
way.
There were strongly nationalist
communist states that still
retained--Hungary,
for example,
or Czechoslovakia that
retained,
even within the satellite
nature,
kind of a pride in trying to
make it work even in 1968,
as Dubcek,
before the tanks roll into
Prague,
tries to make a human-faced
socialism with a Czech and
Slovak face.
Of course, it doesn't work.
Through the whole period,
as everybody knows,
they execute millions of
people.
In World War II,
the figures of the number of
Soviets who die in World War II
is about twenty-five million
people.
If you're thinking about
Stalingrad,
and thinking about the siege of
Leningrad,
which goes on and on and on and
takes a million lives,
but within that twenty-five
million,
lots of those people are people
who died in the gulags.
They did not die from reasons
of war.
They died in the gulags,
and many of them were executed
for being a Kulak,
or being a NEP man,
or whatever.
Can you see this coming?
Can one see this coming?
Just a couple of points along
the way.
During World War I,
states had increased their
power,
their ability to control what
became sort of command economies
to mobilize the resources of the
state.
In Russia in World War I,
the imperial government,
Holquist writes,
"initiated a deportation
of ‘the Jewish
element'--remember,
the rabid anti-Semitism of the
czar and Alexandra--;"on
the borderlines as
‘pernicious,
harmful,
and dangerous to the Russian
people,'"
and thus in wartime they are,
just as in Italy.
Italy went to war in part so
that they had the idea that they
could somehow make citizens
Italian, feel themselves
Italian.
There is this nature as the war
is being fought in Russia that
you will increase the
Russianness of the effort of the
empire,
even though all these other
nationalities are involved,
by excluding people,
by excluding people.
They're not excluding people by
putting them up on the wall and
shooting them.
Nonetheless,
the language is somewhat there.
For example,
they describe the Whites,
who were a nasty group,
many of them,
and just nasty,
bloodthirsty group,
not all of them,
but many of them.
They describe the Jews as
"microbes."
This is the Whites describing
the Jews as "microbes"
and Bolshevism as a
"social disease."
The kind of disease metaphors,
the next step is if you have a
disease, if you have a cancer,
you cut it out.
You exclude it by cutting it
out.
The language of exclusion is
already there.
At one point the Soviets,
in the very first part of the
Soviet Union,
began a program of what they
called
"dekazakhization."
They want to remove an entire
Kazakh population,
which they viewed as
potentially disloyal to the
revolution.
But you can't do that.
It's just too hard to do that
when all these other things are
going on, so they can't do that.
In the early years,
the Lenin years,
you still find these things.
In 1920, when there's a
campaign against banditism,
that is bandits or people who
don't support the
Communists--that term is often
used, by the way,
in France under Vichy,
that the resistors are bandits,
or they're terrorists, etc. etc.
Bandits become a dangerous
epidemic.
Again, the disease metaphor.
They're dangerous because they
are.
In 1920, Stalin informed
Trotsky, Holquist found,
that an order would soon come
directing "the total
extermination of the White
officer corps."
Of course, total extermination
is pretty strong language.
That's not just simply putting
people in jail or in a
re-education camp.
That is getting rid of them.
They create camps which were
called "filter
spaces,"
where people could be kept
until they had seen the light,
etc., etc.
They had all these White
prisoners, some of whom
executed, and the Cheka are the
police who oversee all of this.
That's an obvious term.
Examples from the civil war,
in Holquist's words,
"show the project of
fashioning society by excising
particular elements was an
intrinsic aspect of Soviet power
from the very beginning."
But it's not on the scale that
would come later.
There are lists of people drawn
up in the early 1920s that would
be used in 1937 and 1938,
during the Great Purge.
So, when the campaigns of
collectivization,
which are bloody,
which are massacres,
come along,
the dekulakization campaign,
get rid of the Kulaks,
in 1929-1930,
becomes on a more urgent and
more paranoid scale.
This is the kind of stuff that
we now know from the archives.
A memorandum from March 15 1931
states that with regard to the
Kulaks,
the goal of deportation from
all regions was "to totally
cleanse them of Kulaks."
Another, slightly earlier,
in February,
calls for them to be
"immediately liquidated.
We will exile the Kulak by
thousands and when necessary
shoot the Kulak breed.
We will make soap of the Kulaks.
Our class enemy must be wiped
off from the face of the
earth."
Strong language.
Thus, in 1930,
more than 20,000 Kulaks were
sentenced to death.
Many more are gunned down when
they protest.
And they protest.
They kill their animals rather
than turn them over to the
commissars.
They burn their harvest.
They burn their farm.
These are "weapons of the
weak," as my dear friend,
Jim Scott in the political
science department,
would call it.
Weak indeed they were.
They're confronting these
enormous military forces.
But they fight back.
They fight back.
They just don't go down in a
heap without fighting.
One of the interesting things
about this is just as one of the
key trends in the end of the
nineteenth century is the
origins of
sociology--intellectual trends,
the idea of counting,
and figuring,
and thinking about contemporary
society,
Max Weber and all that.
Really important stuff,
positivism and all of this.
These kinds of censuses
developed way before all this.
The first really accurate
census in France,
outside of municipal ones,
is in 1941.
But what they do is they use
sort of modern tools of
censuses, surveys,
and questionnaires,
to get information on the
entire population.
You'd better be damn careful
when you write down who you are
on one of these forms.
When they say,
"Who is your
grandfather?"
"What did your grandfather
do?"
What are you going to write?
You can't write down he was an
industrial worker if he wasn't.
What if he's a Kulak?
What if he's a noble?
What if he's an Orthodox priest?
You're guilty by association.
Once a Kulak,
once a clergyman,
once an aristocrat,
by class identity you are
guilty.
You are guilty.
They used the censuses of 1926,
and 1937,
and the last one before the war
of 1939,
as a way of deciding who should
get passports and who shouldn't
get passports,
and who should be sent off to
wherever.
By 1934, twenty-seven million
people in the Soviet Union had
been monitored and given state
ID cards.
The French, you had to have an
ID card, also,
to go from one department to
the next,
to go from Marseilles to Nice
you had to have an internal
passport.
What they do,
it's the same state thrust,
except that it has a murderous
outcome.
If you're classifying people,
if you're counting people,
if you're registering people,
this is way before "the
quiet violence of the
computer,"
as Michelle Perrot memorably
put it.
The outcome is very different.
They use archivists.
Some of my friends were
archivists.
They're not going to be doing
this kind of thing.
These are French archivists.
But they're using archivists
who are fearful for their lives.
If you're an archivist with
writing and reading skills,
you're potentially an enemy of
the state, because you're from
the wrong social class.
They say, "We want to look
at your archives.
We want you to find out who's
in what category in your
region."
You better do it.
Archivists in 1939,
according to Holquist,
identify 108,000 enemies of the
people.
Once you're classified as an
enemy of the people,
baby you're toast.
That's it.
You're toast.
Sheila Fitzpatrick is a
wonderful historian.
She was one of the first to
study what she calls "the
extraordinary everydayness"
of Stalinism.
What was life like in a place
where the only way of getting
anything,
and potentially the only way of
surviving,
is your relationship to a
bureaucratic figure?
Stalinism, the essence of state
collectivization,
of state totalitarianism,
is you have to have this
enormous bureaucracy.
It's the bureaucracy that calls
the shots.
Let me put some of the points
that are important.
In getting by,
who are apt to be the militants
in all of this?
Who are apt to be the true
believers in all of this,
the most loyal to the project
of creating this new world,
this new world that never came?
The answer is young people,
younger people.
There were many cases of
younger people denouncing their
parents, being asked to denounce
their parents.
But the most militant and the
most faithful were people who
had not,
who in the 1930s, for example,
if they were twenty-five years
old,
they didn't really remember the
old regime.
They didn't remember the
czarist autocracy.
They are more likely to think
that there's nothing wrong with
trying to decide who still has
religious icons on their walls,
whose parents religiously went
to church.
The young people were more apt
to be the militants in all of
this.
If you were a militant,
what you did was you denounced
class enemies,
these Kulaks and the priests,
members of the
pre-revolutionary nobility,
former capitalists.
Again, once a capitalist,
you are always a capitalist.
Once a Kulak,
you are always a Kulak.
People who had been declared as
"non-toilers,"
that is people who are not
really workers or really
peasants,
who are Kulaks,
they are deprived of the vote,
not that elections subsequently
meant anything in the Soviet
Union,
as early as the constitution of
1918.
These young militants undertake
a war on bourgeois specialists.
One of the problems with the
campaign for rapid
industrialization is they're
really torn.
You need these bourgeois
specialists, because they're
technocrats.
They're the ones that have to
keep up the production count.
They have to keep it up there.
Then you go into this period
and you say, "You can't
have a bunch of bourgeois
specialists who are
educated."
So, those people get
liquidated, maybe not killed but
get removed.
Then they will bring in and
replace them with peasants who
sometimes had absolutely no
education, which is not their
fault at all.
The Soviets do educate people
in this period.
There's a huge increase in
literacy in this period.
But they're turning over
important management positions
within the Soviet Union,
in this push for rapid
industrialization,
to people who can't read and
write,
and really just don't have the
kind of finesse or the kind of
ability to do it.
That causes all sorts of
problems.
The bureaucracy is increasingly
filled with people who are not
competent, but are there because
of their party loyalty.
If you weren't loyal to the
party, there was nowhere you
were going to go.
How does this affect ordinary
Soviet citizens?
There's constant propaganda,
talk about the radiant future,
that enormous sacrifices now
will be worth it in the end.
Marx, after all,
said scientific socialism is
going to take a long time.
Thus, if you see these,
and I've been in the Moscow
subway a long time ago,
but these sort of heroic murals
of the Soviet worker,
the Stakhanovite.
Don't write it down.
I think he's in the book,
but this guy,
Stakhanov,
was a guy who had apparently
set a world record by extracting
the most coal any human had ever
done.
It was basically made up.
But he became this kind of
image of hard work.
I'll tell you,
you'll see a lot of these art
deco murals in Detroit,
Michigan.
Or, for example,
I'm not making this as an
analogy,
but there was the equivalent
under National Socialism,
also,
the idea of the German worker
toiling away and all that,
with the interests of the state.
Basically it's the idea that
Russia could be moved by hard
work out of backwardness toward
this radiant future.
It does keep people going.
There's always this contrast
between "then,"
the bad old days when these
folks ruled--the NEP men,
and the Kulaks,
and the aristocracy,
and all of that--and the
inevitable future.
The landlords were gone.
There's collective ownership of
the means of production,
so everything has got to be
okay.
The motto is,
"The party is always
right," and you'd better
believe it.
The state shaped the way people
lived.
Part of it, those people lived
through the purge.
I'll tell you a story.
I had this colleague a long,
long time ago when I first came
here who grew up in Moscow in
the 1930s.
His father was the Persian
ambassador to Moscow.
In the purges people were now
seeing their parents,
and people were being taken
away in the night,
and there were boots in the
hall,
and it was a pretty damn scary
time to live.
One day he was in this big
school.
He was in
collège,
middle school.
He's twelve years old,
basically.
He is sitting in one of these
big buildings there,
and the bell rings to go from
one class to the next class.
The bell rang and the guy who
was sitting in front of him,
a twelve-year-old boy,
gets up.
He puts his cartable
down, his book carrier down,
and he goes out.
They're on the fifth floor.
He goes to the stairwell and he
jumps over to his death,
just like that.
He stepped over the thing and
fell.
If you're twelve years old
you're going to remember that
kind of thing.
He didn't know,
because you didn't discuss such
things,
whether he had denounced his
parents and felt badly about it,
or whether his parents had been
taken away and he didn't have
any idea where they were.
This was one of the tragedies
also.
A lot of it is self-deception.
These were very poor people.
You believe in the radiant
future.
This is a very, very poor place.
You saw these Stalin
skyscrapers.
There's a big debate in Warsaw
whether the one that's there
should be kept.
You saw more literacy.
You saw sometimes products on
the market.
But the deception was there.
The great hopes were there.
The reality was completely
different.
You would have bizarre things
happen.
Suddenly, you have state
planning.
For a while there were all
these red female stockings on
the market.
That was supposed to be cool.
You had a lot of Western
visitors who had seen these same
female red stockings,
which were very much
"in"
in Paris and Berlin.
But this wasn't Paris and
Berlin.
This was Moscow.
Suddenly, you have a lot of
that.
Someone thought,
"Ketchup will look good to
the outsiders when they
come."
So, they start producing
ketchup.
There's nothing to put the
ketchup on.
The most ridiculous example
I've ever heard is that they
started producing lots of
bathtubs,
because people are waiting in
line to get apartments,
which was true until 1992.
They're waiting in line to get
apartments, though things got a
lot better after World War II,
but still.
If you're going to have an
apartment that is of progress,
the radiant future,
you've got to have a bathtub.
So, they produce all these
bathtubs, but they forget to
produce corks or stoppers.
So, for a long time you had
people that were lucky enough to
have bathtubs,
but the water just runs out and
they could show them off to
their friends.
It simply doesn't work.
But there is the illusion,
and I'm going to have to end
with this, because I went too
long earlier.
There's more to say but there's
always more to say.
There was the illusion.
There were lots of true
believers and people who also
wanted a radiant future.
In the late 1960s,
please, not the early ones,
and the 1970s,
we were all dealing with our
ideology of the weak.
I had an uncle who meant a
great deal to me who was a
communist.
He was trained in Berlin as a
psychoanalyst.
He worked for a Communist
newspaper, and he claimed to
have know Georgie Dimitrov,
the Bulgarian communist leader.
He was a true believer always.
At the end of his life he ended
up passing, or having his wife
pass Save the Will petitions.
He was no longer a communist.
But I remember when I was a
little boy him telling me that
the people trying to escape from
communism were psychotic.
That people trying to get over
the wall in Berlin were
psychotic for trying to leave
this radiant future of a
workers' paradise.
There were a lot of true
believers.
These people,
a lot of them,
and I'm not dissing my uncle
whom I loved deeply,
and who meant a great deal in
my life, and especially my aunt.
They believed.
People would go to these show
trials and they would see people
saying,
"Yes, I was in cahoots
with Romanian fascists,"
or with Dutch fascists,
or with Georgian nationalists,
or something like that.
They would admit to all sorts
of things, possibly hoping it
was going to save their lives.
It didn't. It never did.
They were executed.
Stalin executed them all.
He executed the entire general
staff practically of the army.
One of the most amazing things
about the Second World War is
how the Red Army not only
survived but won,
and retrained people.
There weren't any admirals left.
There was nobody left.
He killed them all.
But people continued to believe.
They believed.
The whole phrase,
maybe you've heard of the
phrase, "a Potemkin
village."
I guess that's a good place to
end--a Potemkin village.
For example,
if you're watching an old TV
western and you see a
façade,
you've got the bar,
and you've got Miss Kitty,
and you've got all of this,
and a few people punching each
other out;
there's nothing behind it.
It's just all a fraud.
It's nothing.
They would bring these visitors
from the West in this brave new
industrial world,
and they'd see parts of towns
that had been reshaped.
They meet the first literate
people in a family.
It was very true.
Some good things happened, too.
But they were far outweighed by
the bad things.
But a Potemkin village would
be, you'd go and you'd see this
façade and you'd be
whisked through.
"This is where the
children's railroad will
be."
"This is where the
kindergarten is going to
be."
It's always the "going to
be," and it never happened.
That, I suppose,
is the tragedy of the Russian
Revolution.
Arguably, maybe,
who knows, a good idea gone
terribly, terribly bad.